>> Alright, so now we have a way to, to look at our modified version using a
file on our local machine, but it would
be really nice if we could you know, share
this with our friends without passing them all
of the files that we modified and having them
loaded up on their computer. So what we did
was we made this shareable version hosted on GitHub.
>> Yeah, and GitHub does this automatically, it's
pretty cool, it's this feature called gh-pages. And we,
Sara and I just went through the whole process of making that happen and it
was actually a little frustrating, not for any
good reason, mostly because we were impatient. So
there is a link in the instructor comments
of this video that will give you great
documentation for how to make your own page.
The only advice I think we would give.
>> Be patient.
>> Yes. There's a part where it says it may take
ten minutes. It really means that, so don't, don't think anything's
going wrong if your page isn't loading as fast as you think.
>> Yep.
>> But, once you have your, your page up, you should go to
the forum, share your link and I'm really excited to see what everyone makes.
>> Yeah.